and i'm so thrilled right now because
et's melissa johnson joins me
to talk about the governor's award which
of course is going to tyler perry this
year and alicia i understand
that tyler is someone that you have a
very strong connection to
i do leanne i grew up in atlanta georgia
and being someone who wanted to enter
the entertainment industry
he was a huge inspiration he actually
offered me one of my first positions
as a production assistant after i
graduated college so
it was a wonderful experience working
with him it also was a wonderful
experience to be a part of his studio
his team
you know he was the first african
american to independently own
a studio which is major there's just
so much to love about this guy
human stories you know we all have the
same experiences
he learned so i was while everybody's
fighting for a seat at the table i was
down in atlanta building my own table i
don't want to get into a fight that i
didn't need to get into
because i don't think that that's where
the change is even though protest is
wonderful for a lot of people that was
great getting get in there make people
feel differently about it
wonderful but for me my thing is build
your own studio own your own life
on your own space on your own content
and hire as many people of color as you
can
and women that's how you create
diversity for me so i celebrate
everybody who was fighting for it but i
was on the other side of building my own
table
every corner has a color i'm hoping that
we all come together and stand together
and start having some conversations
to help fix this because as long as
people in their color in their corners
with their colors you know with swords
and knives i don't think we're ever
going to get anything done so
i just want to see some unity to happen
and that what that only way that happens
is from leadership from the top down
you're chocolate
that's a new way of saying black i'm
chocolate yes african-american
tyler perry looking amazing can we talk
about the jackpot it's on board tom
board
yeah yeah shoes okay tyler ford tom
board yeah i stick with what works tom
ford
yeah that's right that's right that's
right where are we looking excuse me
while i do my tyra banks
you know we all got to do it man we all
got to help each other what good is one
person making it if somebody else can't
make it and somebody else can't make it
you know
so when you do it you like my angelo
said when you learn teach
so it's about that's what it was about
for me man holding the door open and for
all those people
whose dreams may be on life support i
want you to walk past this
star in particular and know that i've
been there how are you dealing with this
and especially on a night like tonight
where
all of hollywood is pretty much here i'm
taking it in one by one moment by moment
i'm really just being
grateful and thankful and and just i'm
taking it in tonight i am determined to
take it in i'm determined to take it
it makes sense though hallelujah
hallelujah
now all those other people of color have
an opportunity to tell their stories
from ryan coogler to ava duvenay to
barry jenkins these are
beautiful storytellers and i'm loving
them having the opportunity to do their
thing
so i can do mine without as much
judgment as before because if you don't
like what tyler perry is doing go see
somebody else's
maybe you're represented in somebody
else's movie of color it's what i mean